première conclusion c'est que la
dissuasion nucléaire fonctionne tout le
monde sait enfin je trouve il y a peu de
choses où on peut être sûr de sûr mais
si l'Ukraine avait eu la bombe Poutine
n'aurait pas attaqué si Poutine n'avait
pas la bombe il n'aurait pas attaqué
parce qu'il aurait craint des riposte
beaucoup plus fortes sur son territoire
et si les Occidentaux n'avaient pas la
bombe et ben il est fort probable que
Poutine en aurait profité pour aller en
Lituanie ou ailleurs en tout cas il
serait beaucoup moins prudent pour
éviter l'escalade donc on a une
démonstration en grandeur réelle que la
dissuasion nucléaire fonctionne
par contre ce n'est pas l'alpha et
l'oméga de la sécurité mondiale mais ça
on le savait on le savait
donc sous le sous le pas sous le
parapluie nucléaire ou sous la voûte
nucléaire il peut se passer des choses
et des tensions et le monde nous le
montre deuxième
conséquence générale technique
opérationnelle enfin qui pas propre à la
Marine qui générale qui moi me marque
c'est le fameux débat sur technologie
versus masse masse étant quantité
logistique soutien BITD de la masse
c'est vraiment ça c'est que la capacité
de produire des outils militaires
c'est un débat sans fin et à mon avis
c'est un débat qui n'a pas il n'y a pas
un vainqueur d'ailleurs ce qui se passe
en Ukraine tout le monde d'un côté
l'Ukraine et l'Occident c'est la
technologie de l'autre côté la Russie
c'est la masse et on voit qu'on arrive à
un espèce de statu quo parce que il
manque toujours de la masse à l'ouest et
de la technologie à l'est et donc il
faut les deux il faut les deux je pense
à un débat hyper stérile de dire
privilégions l'un plutôt que l'autre
moi j'ai le sentiment qu'il est plus
facile de développer de la masse quand
on a de la techno que développer la
techno quand on a de la masse je
pourrais développer si vous le souhaitez
cette idée donc on part sur ce plan là
on ne part pas avec un désavantage mais
parce qu'on a de la technologie à
l'ouest et on en a encore en France je
dis encore parce que on a on a bien un
petit peu perdu